de varios sectores a lo largo de la
semana ya se había anticipado que el
presidente de los eeuu joe biden
podría reconocer el genocidio armenio es
decir catalogar estas atrocidades
cometidas contra el pueblo armenio en
1915 como genocidio no cuestión que fue
desviada por los presidentes anteriores
por supuesto que este reconocimiento
tuvo mucho que ver con el arduo trabajo
que han hecho las comunidades armenias
de los eeuu quienes trabajaron
incansablemente durante largos años este
reconocimiento puede llegar a debilitar
tal vez las relaciones de los eeuu con
turquía pero es un riesgo que el
presidente maiden ha asumido para
colocar en la política exterior de su
país del lado de los derechos humanos no
por sobre cualquier otro golpe
geoestratégico que esto pueda significar